يقهر الجيش الذي شاع الوهم طوال ثمانيه
عقود بانه لا
يقهر تتهاوى اسطورته العسكريه امام بساله
ضحاياه في محطه مدهشه من سفر كفاحهم
التاريخي الطويل لانتزاع حقوقهم كبشر وحيث
ينجح بضع مئات من هؤلاء باذلال جنده
المدربين على احدث فنون القتال او القتل
وتمريض هيبته في وحل بلادهم فانه لا يجد
وسيله
لترميم صورته امام ذاته وامام العالم غير
تسخير التكنولوجيا الحربيه الجبانه
للانتقام من مدنيين عزل في مخيمات لاجئين
كانت شكلت منذ تاسيسها ولا تزال دليلا على
جريمه اقتلاع شعب من دياره لتقام عليها
دوله اغراب جاؤوا اليها غزاه خلال القرن
الماضي من وراء المحيطات انه يسترد الان
تفوقه او هكذا يظن قادته بارسال الطائرات
المقاتله التي لا حاجه بمستخدميه لاي حد
من الشجاعه كي تقصف وتدمر وتقتل فيتحول
مئات من احفاد وابناء ضحاياه السابقين الى
ضحايا جدد في ثوان
قليله هذا مخيم جباليا للاجئين
الفلسطينيين في قطاع غزه وهؤلاء هم من
استطاع الجيش الاسرائيلي الانتصار عليهم
او هكذا يظن قادته مره اخرى بعد مرور
يومين على سقوط عشرات من معاقله الحصينه
امام زحف رجال المقاومه الفلسطينيه وفي
مقدمتهم مقاتلوا كتائب عز الدين القسام
الذراع المسلحه لحركه
حماس لكن جواب السؤال عن افاق ظن القاده
الاسرائيليين بقدرتهم على انقاذ كرامه
جيشهم واعاده عقارب الزمان الى ما قبل
طوفان الاقصى سيولد المزيد من الاسئله عن
اثم بناء التفوق العسكري بجماجم المدنيين
الابرياء وما ظل يؤدي اليه من نتائج وخيمه
عبر التاريخ لا على حياه الضحايا
المستعمرين فحسب بل على مصائر الجنات
المستعمرين انفسهم
كذلك ستنزلق اسرائيل تحت ضغط النزف
المتدفق من كرامتها الجريحه الى ان تكشف
المعتقد الاخطر الكامن وراء شنها الحروب
المتكرره على الفلسطينيين وقتلهم بالجمله
منذ دير ياسين وحتى
جباليا اننا نحارب حيوانات بشريه قال وزير
الفاع الدوله اليهوديه مبررا اعلانه فرض
حصار شامل على قطاع غزه يشمل قطع الماء
والكهرباء والغذاء عن ملايين البشار
المحشورين في بقعه جغرافيه تقل مساحتها عن
400 ك متر مربع طبعا من دون ان يتذكر او
يذكره اي من حلفاء دولته الغربيين بمدى
تماهيه مع ايديولوجيه عنصريه مشابهه كان
اسلافه اليهود الاوروبيون ضحايا لها خلال
القرن الماضي على النقيض من تصريحات
الوزير الاسرائيلي سيسجل مقاتلو القسام ما
يعكس حرصهم على تحقيق التفوق الاخلاقي
فضلا عن القتالي عندما دخلوا منزلا في
احدى المستوطنات التي سيطروا عليه
ووجدوا فيه نساء واطفا ووصيه رسول الله
صلى الله عليه وسلم لنا نحن المسلمون
المجاهدون الا نقتل امراه ولا طفلا ولا
شيخا ولا عابدا في
صومعته استطرادا في تقصي اجوبه الاسئله عن
الرهانات الاسرائيليه هناك بين الخبراء
العسكريين من يتحدث الان عن انتهاج سياسه
الارض المحروقه وثمت في اوساط المحللين
الفلسطينيين من يصف غارات اليوم بانها غير
مسبوقه في قدرتها التدميريه وتكاد تكون
اشبه بحروب
الابا رغم ذلك لا احد يتوقع امكانيه
القضاء على قوى المقاومه او دفع الشعب
الفلسطيني الى رفع رايات الاستسلام امام
بطش القوه العسكريه الاسرائيليه تجارب
المواجهه بين الجانبين تنحي تماما اي
احتمال من هذا القبيل لتحر الجدوى المتوقع
من الحرب في رفع منسوب قتل الفلسطينيين
عله يعيد اقناع المستوطنين بقدره الدوله
على حمايتهم ليكفوا عن التدفق على مطار بن
جوريون فيما يبدو مستهل هجره معاكسه الى
بلدانهم الاصليه التي جاؤوا منها وما زال
كثيرون منهم يحملون
جنسياتها